do you watch CSI law-and-order NCIS
I like how those crime shows use modern
science to get the bad guy grabs prints
are all over singers convertible the
pollen that was in Petty Officer Vicks
lungs is found only one place on earth
people who watch these shows believe
that this is how it's really done
it's not it's not former detective Harry
Hulk's annoyed that the TV shows make
forensic science look infallible and you
watch a detective get down and look at a
body and touch you know he's been dead
for three hours now he ate dinner four
hours ago I can't do that on TV experts
identify the killer
by his bite mark a little 3d magic for
clarity and I give you the killer's
incisors in real life experts claim they
can identify criminals that way Swinton
was convicted and sentenced to 60 years
in prison based on testimony that bite
marks found on the victim were his the
TV show cold-case files covered the
trial in which Alfred Swinton was
convicted because this so-called bite
mark expert said Swinton's teeth matched
a bite on the victim when the models of
the teeth were laid onto the bite mark
it was a perfect match the expert
explained
he's a neutral scientist a forensic
scientist is not on the side of the
prosecution of defense we look at the
evidence and we make sure that if we're
going to make a decision it's going to
be a truthful decision the doctor is
this wrong
he was this wrong because it's an
unreliable technique it looks like
science it does they're in white lab
coats they sound very authoritative but
they're full of it lawyer Cris fabric
Adelle Pitts written freed from jail by
doing a DNA test new DNA evidence shows
he had nothing to do with the 1991
murder of Carla Terry tonight Alfred
Swinton's conviction was vacated and
he's a free man that's Chris fabricant
celebrating with Swinton the day he was
released by Marx is similar to you and I
maybe looking at a cloud and then I say
to you as a John doesn't that cloud look
like a rabbit to you and you
yeah Chris I think that does look like a
rabbit but that kind of junk science
puts innocent people in jail that's one
or two people many more people are in
jail and we're supposedly safer because
of that if you think that maybe even 1%
of convicted defendants may have been
innocent
we have 2.6 million people in prison
today so we're not talking about a
couple of people we're talking about
tens of thousands of people but the
people who use these techniques they
believe in it they're confident sure
their confidence faith based science the
expert who got swidden convicted now
admits he was wrong
but police still trust bite marks let's
say one tooth is missing in the front so
you got to look at that and you go your
suspects got one tooth missing in the
front that's pretty good
but then again that's not enough Houck
says he'd demand other evidence but not
all cops do especially if experts say
they're sure someone's guilty when they
say so you trust that yes but even
fingerprint evidence isn't foolproof the
deadliest terror attack on Europe since
World War two when terrorists in Madrid
killed 193 people the FBI found this
fingerprint on one of the terrorist bags
and matched it to this fingerprint of a
man in Oregon an international
investigation led to Brandon Mayfield
however two weeks after Mayfield's
arrest Spanish investigators found the
man to whom the fingerprint really
belonged FBI researchers claimed
fingerprints are right more than 99% of
the time but that still leaves plenty of
wrongful convictions other techniques
are even less accurate carpet fiber
evidence gun tracing hair matching
microscopic hair comparison evidence has
been admitted by courts for a century in
one case it was a dog's hair a dog hair
was associated wrongfully with a human
hair since the turn of this century
there have been 75 wrongful convictions
and fabricant works for the Innocence
Project by using more modern DNA
evidence the project's lawyers have
helped free 191 innocent people all
these
people were wrongly jailed based on
so-called scientific evidence why do
judges admit this stuff right dude do I
don't defense attorneys get it thrown
out
we all went to law school because we
don't know science we don't know math
and if somebody comes in with a white
lab coat and says I've been accredited
by the American Board of forensic
odontology and I've been practicing for
20 years that's good enough for
government work that shouldn't be the
standard too much is at stake
jurors tend to believe people who courts
call experts
but the experts often rely on junk
science juries and judges should be much
more skeptical